[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the brand new Last of Us
trailer released at the end of episode 1
this gives us a lot of insight at what's
coming in episode 2 and the weeks ahead
throughout this video we're going to be
talking about the characters Easter eggs
and what we think will happen due to
what happens in the game because of this
there'll probably be some Major Spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything then I highly suggest that you
turn off now if you enjoy the video
please smash the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
on the show every week by the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
The Last of Us trailer
now episode 1 ended with the group
heading on to Boston and then we got the
shot of the iconic skyscrapers pulled
directly from the game this is probably
the next stop and I can imagine episode
2 will send it around them heading out
into the city like what they do in the
game their first stop was these
skyscrapers which we see later on in the
teaser except this time it's happening
in the daylight in the game you found
that the road of the State Building had
been destroyed unless you had to climb
up the left one of these before
descending into the right here you ran
into clickers for the first time after
discovering one attached to the wall and
you made your way into the basement
before popping up on the other side huge
alerts to everyone on our last video for
pointing out that there was actually a
glimpse at a clicker on the rooftop in
the storm which I missed so call that
video everything I missed and hit the
thumbs down button if you don't mind
anyway they did some really cool things
with the physics in the skyscrapers
especially the one at an angle and I
can't wait to see how this is brought
into the show the skyscrapers look so
good in the trailer and they're one of
the most iconic landmarks that pop up in
the game and the fact they're traveling
on this journey is cemented by the Civil
War Museum that opens up the new look in
the game after you made it through the
skyscrapers you passed into this and it
was full of infected they really managed
to recapture the look of it with antique
muskets and weapons being in display
cases that we see the group hiding
behind the click has sound absolutely
terrifying and in case you don't know
these are infected people who've had
cordyceps so long that it's actually
grown out of their eyes and making them
blind when you first hit by them they
slowly attach to your brain and this is
so that they can start to control your
behavior from here they start to sprout
out through the body and eventually they
eat their way out the front of your face
and then being blind is why they're
referred to as clickers because they use
echolocation as a way to see they've got
highly tuned hearing so you have to be
more silent than a thought and a lift
and this is why we see Joel and Cole
standing behind the display echolocation
works by them hearing sound bouncing off
the back of something and thus if they
were out in the urban they'd instantly
pick up on them now because they're
blind they aren't elated a flashlight
which is why Jill can stand there
shining by right like a diamond now over
the top of this we hear Ellie asking
Jill if he's ever killed an infected
person before and mirroring this we can
see her approaching one under Rubble
with a knife drawn this is at the
stalker stage in which they've been
infected for a while and the fungus is
slowly starting to transform their face
now this kind of sums up the infected
and what the creative team are really
going for when they start to design them
they're very much supposed to be
sympathetic villains and when you come
across them in the game you'd often find
them whipping away in the corner I can
imagine having a parasite attach itself
to your brain and slowly sending your
mental isn't a very pleasant experience
and it's also eating away a tit is
probably more painful than heavy
spoilers pun that's very much the
feeling I get from my guy Bonnie Rubble
here with him very much being at the
mercy of Ellie she moves her knife over
his head and mirroring the clickers we
can also see the fungus growing out of
his eye just doesn't seem like he's a
very fun guy a fun guy and I did warn
you about them puns to be fair I warned
you so it's your fault now here we get
Jill and now he sat down talking and I'm
not sure where this is but I'm guessing
it happens quite early on due to how
much gel shuts down the conversation she
asks if he finds it difficult killing
the infected knowing that they were
people but as we know he doesn't even
mind killing people even if they're
people anyway from here we get a shot at
a character who was touched upon in the
first episode and actually got a lot of
filled in about how the show is going to
be handling things looks like they're
adapting the additional DLC left behind
and this basically goes in depth on what
happened to Ellie the night she got bit
this had us meeting Riley and we learn
in episode one that she was with Ellie
when she got infected Ellie was training
at a federal Camp which he was drafted
into as a child but a best friend Riley
had a runoff to join the fireflies she
showed up one night and pulled her out
of her room and we learned that she was
being shipped off to a place in Atlanta
the next day she basically wanted to
have one last night with Ellie and she
took her to an abandoned Mall in the qz
that was completely off limits here they
rode the Merry-Go-Round which we see
playing out in the trailer it's
basically a date for the pair and they
end up kissing at the end of it with
Ellie asking Riley to stay she says yes
but it's cut short by the infected
swarming them and both the pair get bit
now we see Ellie looking at her arm and
you might also notice that in the shot
before that she's wearing the T-shirt
she was in episode one we know she was
picked up by the fireflies and was
wearing this when she was chained up so
this likely leads directly into episode
1. now from here we go to the group
walking along the street with a Boston
State Building directly in front of them
when you made your way through this part
of the game you had that constantly off
in the background with a golden dome
acting very much is a waypoint and from
here we get shots of the scene in Boston
with pests saying that they're just
trying to keep her alive we then get
additional shots in the museum sea
rifles and then a clicker screaming
directly at them now from here we get a
shot that I really don't recognize from
the game you see a person in a truck
rushing towards a gate man looking at
them we can make out a cap and that they
have shoulder length hair they seem to
be on their own and this leads into the
build scenes so I'm I'm guessing that
it's him we catch him in his hometown
Lincoln which was the next stop after
Boston here we see Bill and Frank with
Aletta being someone that we never
actually met in the game now by the time
Ali and gel arrived at Lincoln he'd ran
away from Bell and he'd try to make a
break for it by stealing a truck battery
from a military Caravan this failed
unless Joe and Ellie were able to get it
and make their own way using the truck
he'd stolen it seems like we're getting
way more of their relationship played
out as we see Bill warning there's no
friends out there and then a flash of
the Town being attacked we can catch
Frank with a gun drawn and what looks
like people burning torches standing off
in the background I'm guessing that Bell
takes these out using his traps which
were something that appeared as he moved
through Lincoln the idea of them not
having friends is then cemented in the
next shot in which we see Kathleen
played by Melanie Linsky this is a brand
new character for the show that looks
like she's leading a large group of
rebels now from the other trailers we
could see that she seemed to be located
in Pittsburgh which was ham at home by
the truck with run written on the front
of it she's in a position of power
hauling a gun to someone's head and
according to the reviews she's going to
be a really big character we then get
what I'm guessing as the siege of
Pittsburgh which is carried up by the
rebels Pedro ran most of the qzs but
since they were pretty much fascists
that would hang people for going outside
descent started to rise amongst the
citizens they form their own groups and
took over but whether they were better
or not is another thing entirely they
were just as bad as Federal were if not
worse and they'd Rob and kill people who
came into the city now on the opposite
side of this were peaceful settlements
such as Jackson which we see in the next
shot if you look in the top left you can
catch a sign Freya with advertising the
Lights Festival 2003 the game took place
in 2013 whereas the series starts off in
2003 so that the 20-year time Jump can
take us to present day looks looks
bloody better than the world we live in
to be fair and I I wish I was there
anyway topical so uh moving on Jackson
wasn't really a place that we really
went to in the first game and it was
only in the second one that we got to
walk around it obviously the showrunners
have the gift of hindsight so they can
sell the seeds for season two and we
even have another the second game in
this wide shot of the town to the right
we see the Tipsy bison and this was the
bar in the game where a big scene went
down this involved Joel and Ellie and
I'm guessing that they might even visit
this at some point and we can see the
seeds being sown and we then see Tommy
sporting facial hair and he's one of the
high-ranking citizens that lets the pair
stay Joel initially wants Tommy to take
Ellie to the fireflies due to him being
an ex-member but after Ellie runs off
Jay dog ends up doing it later on we see
Tommy closing the get on them this is
possibly him saying goodbye to jail
before they head out on the rest of
their Adventure now next we catch Joe
looking at his watch in a rooftop and
this is Paul directly from a scene in
Boston Joel has a moment where he looks
at it as if to remember Sarah and it's a
really subtle and touching moment that
kind of displaces thoughts and from here
we see Sam and Henry who are survivors
that we meet in Pittsburgh they'll
probably be helping the group Escape
clean and interestingly you can see
Henry talking in Sign Language number of
reasons for this potentially including
deafness obviously though he is in death
in the game so I don't know if it's
exactly that gone in a theme a few times
quickly there you didn't expect that
won't come in my suit
you do
so it is possible I could be using this
to silently communicate with each other
in order to stay quiet and they might
have had to learn this to not draw
attention to themselves obviously
clickers are going to be a big thing in
the show so that could be a reason for
it or they might want to just keep quiet
as they move through this city is a few
times
now next we see some Infected and
climbing out of the ground these were
heavily infected people let it basically
mutate into massive hulking monsters
that were capable of throwing toxic gas
and acid at the character they were
completely terrifying and some of the
scariest things that he came across in
the game which do not make me go back to
that hotel basement mate I'm not bloody
going back
now next we see shots of Jill about to
smash smash smash smash and then click
is attacking Ellie and lastly what I
think is a shot from the final episode
I'm gonna give you another quick spoiler
warning just in case you don't want the
ending Rune but but but you're still
here they do eventually make it at the
fireflies and then stuff goes down worse
and HBO probably canceling this after
one season because Warner Brothers have
no chill now Ellie and Joe will actually
make it to the fireflies and upon
arriving there they almost drown which
is when they're picked up by the group
Jolene awakens in hospital with Marlene
at his bedside and he discovers that
they're prepping alley for surgery to
remove this strain from her brain only
problem is is that this will kill her
and this Jill goes Rambo on the entire
place and kills all the soldiers and
doctors I think this is what we see
playing out here as he's clearly walking
through a corridor and mercilessly
shooting at people anyway that closes
out the trailer and though we're only
one episode down I have really high
hopes for the C season if they can keep
this standard for how it was in episode
1 then we're in for one of the best
video game adaptations ever by quite a
large margin so that's it I hope you
enjoyed the video and make sure you stay
locked to the channel for breakdowns on
the series every week linked on screen
right now we have our bright end of
episode 1 which has every Easter egg in
it except except for the clicker at the
end hopefully you enjoy it though and
thanks for sitting with me until the end
of the video by the way thanks for
watching I've been Paul you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace